Welcome to the second part of the uh AI
in chemistry and biology lecture. Um
last time we talked about sequence-based
models. Um then also protein structure
prediction and um after that structure
based models and today we will mainly
talk about the generative models for
denovo design of proteins and small
molecules. But before that I would like
to um make a small excursion and talk
about uh the challenges associated with
training machine learning models on
biological data. That is um what we will
start with right after like a short
recap of what we've learned last week
because many of these uh basic things
will be important again today. So we
have seen that proteins are chains of
amino acids
and there are these 20 standard amino
acids that all proteins are built from
and all these amino acids they have a
backbone. So that is this triangle of N
C alpha and and C atoms here that are
common to all amino acids. And then what
differentiates the 20 amino acids from
each other is what is what is attached
here at the C alpha atom um which is
called the side chain that gives the
amino acid its specific properties.
And then
um small molecules, we've seen that this
these are just organic compounds that
are relatively small. So their structure
um usually allows to synthesize them
quite easily in in a chemical lab. And
most drugs are small molecules because
they um can enter cells, bind to
proteins, and so affect some biological
processes. And so the chemical structure
and the composition of small molecules
defines its function. And therefore if
you engineer small molecules you change
these to achieve some specific
interaction patterns with desired
proteins.
Yeah. And we've looked at um alpha fold
2 to fold protein sequences um into
their native structures. And we've seen
that uh after taking this protein
sequence that you would like to fold,
alpha fold enters this genetic uh
genetic database and makes a multiple
sequence alignment. And then it also um
checks a structure database for
structures of related proteins that
might already exist.
And then it takes a guess of the first
version of the pair-wise uh distances
between all amino acids in the protein
using these templates. And then all
these uh this information is is
processed by the main main architecture
of all fold into um a protein structure
that is then also refined using this
recycling strategy.
And we've also seen that um because
proteins rarely act alone but usually
interact with other small molecules or
um DNA or RNA the recent folding models
they also include other biomolelecules
such as like metal ions and small
molecules and DNA um and then predict um
immediately like the structure of the
whole complex. So you give them a
sequence and maybe also smiles code of a
small molecule and then they might
predict um firstly this structure of the
protein but also at the same time the
binding confirmation of this HIV
protease inhibitor to to this enzyme
and then we've looked at graph
convolutional neuronet networks that
these are very well suited to model
unordered data such as social networks
or molecules
And these GNN's they transform um the
embeddings that are stored in the nodes
of the graph and the edges of the graph
maybe also a global context vector
through message passing and then the
resulting embeddings in these structures
um include information about the
connectivity and the neighborhoods of
the nodes and edges.
And we've also seen that this GNN's can
be useful to model molecules and
proteins. So they can be used for
prediction of properties of small
molecules like that model that predicted
uh antibacterial activity. They can be
used for protein function prediction or
also as we have seen for uh the
prediction of binding affinity between
proteins and ligans.
All right, I hope that refreshes the
most important things we've seen last
week. And now I would like to transition
to um the challenges that we face when
training machine learning models on
biological data and then also show some
examples of uh models that
um emphasize these challenges.
So biological data uh commonly comes
from um databases that are um based on
community contributions. So that could
be uniro is is a database of of protein
sequences and the functional
annotations. Uh the protein data bank
you've heard that a couple of times is a
database of protein and other
macroolelecular structures. And then
popcam would be another chemical
database. But these are built on like
the contributions of thousands of uh
researchers that deposit their
structures and experimental results in
these databases.
And this brings a couple of problems
like first of all um data is still
scarce. So highly high quality labeled
biological data um is not so easy to
find. So the protein data bank for
example contains about 250,000
structures. But then if you want to
predict binding affinity and train a
model to predict binding affinities
between proteins and small molecules
then um the data set of labeled
complexes is about 20,000 or so.
And then the data quality and the noise
levels are a problem because these
biological data sets often contain high
noise levels because of variability in
the experimental conditions and essays
that people use to generate this data.
And there are also often missing values,
measurement errors or just incomplete
annotations.
And there's also a lot of data imbalance
present in these data sets because
there's an over representations of
certain uh classes or for example
wellstudied proteins such as the HIV
protease that we've seen before and an
under representation of other less
interesting proteins.
So the first problem I would like to
talk about is this bias and redundancy
problems. So, as I've mentioned, these
data sets may be biased towards
wellstudied proteins and contain a lot
of redundancies because of that because
many researchers um deposit structures
of the same um kind. And these
redundancies are very often not really
recognized because the data type is so
complex. So um it's not so trivial to
find that two structures like this are
actually show the identical interaction
patterns between this small molecule and
this protein.
So people frequently use like wrong
proxies for similarity such as um using
just a protein sequence identity um as a
measure of protein liant complex
similarity.
And that that doesn't work because um
complexes with a low sequence identity
so that share a small only a small part
of of their sequence can still have
identical um interaction patterns
between uh proteins and lians.
And then models are usually or very
often trained on these highly redundant
but not very diverse data sets often
with like undetected overlap between the
training and the testing data.
And an example for that would be in this
task of structure based binding affinity
prediction. So where you predict the
interaction strength of a protein and
the small molecule from their
three-dimensional interaction um
structure and the main data set that is
used for that um is this PDB bind
database that collects all um these
complexes from the protein datab bank
and designs um searches affinity labels
for it and this uh contains a lot of
redundancies
arising from multiple experiment
experiments on on the same protein. And
then usually this uh CASF so comparative
assessment of scoring functions uh
benchmark data set is used to um compare
different models and assess
generalization
and this was initially designed to
benchmark classical physics- based
scoring algorithms and it was sampled
from like sequence similarity clusters
in in this PTB bind and there are more
than 20 um peer-reviewed and published
models that train on this
um train and test evaluation setup
and there have always been these like
data leakage concerns in this in this
field. So we decided to look a bit more
closely into that and we um computed
three pair wise metrics for the entire
database
including the CSF benchmark. So we
looked at the ligan similarity. This is
the first column here which is basically
just a tonimoto similarity between um
countbased molecular fingerprints of the
ligans. We looked at protein similarity
which uses like tmalign um a tool to
find the optimal alignment of uh the 3D
structures of two proteins and
outputting a score between zero and one.
And then finally we also looked at the
binding confirmation. So we computed an
RMSD between all the liant atoms after
pocket alignment using TML. And this
resulted in three pair-wise similarity
matrices uh each based on about 190
million comparisons.
And then we used these pair-wise
similarity matrices. combined them to
find the train test pairs that were most
similar in terms of all three metrics
and then also compared their binding
affinity label that is used to train
these models. Then we found um plenty of
structures like this with um
test complexes with the protein in gray
and the liant in red and train complexes
with the protein in blue and the liant
in green that are basically the same. Uh
so you have identical lians, identical
proteins, same affinity and just a tiny
deviation in in the liant positioning.
And then this would be another example
that is almost the same or you would we
even found just straight duplicates
um just complexes between like pairs in
training and testing where I needed to
shift like the the structure of the
ligan of one that you would even see
that there are two.
Uh so we had to conclude that there is
like a train test data leakage between
this PDB bind database and the CASF
benchmark with about 600 training
complexes being nearly identical to a
test complex in terms of these uh core
metrics. So almost half of the benchmark
data sets do not present challenge to
models trained on the PDB bind database.
Nevertheless, almost all machine
learning based scoring functions are
trained in this setup in the recent
years uh using the CSF benchmark to
measure the generalization and compared
to other models. And you can see the the
published uh performances of these
models here with an RMSSE between the
true and the predicted um binding
affinity.
And we then retrained two models. So
this pavesy a 3D CNN a really old one
from 2018 I think and this gen score a
GNN and we found that all models in this
list are like outperformed by the oldest
model when it is retrained on the newest
data. So we used the 3D CNN. It actually
turned out to be um the best in this
setup. And then one model is also
outperformed
um by simple lookup algorithms that we
devised that just for each test complex
search for the five most similar
training complexes and average their um
affinity label to make a prediction for
the test complex. This this performance
here. And then we also made a a search
algorithm that just um searches for the
training complexes with the five most
similar ligans and also averages the
their labels. And this performance you
can see here.
And then some models are outperformed by
um a model that is trained only on
lians. So you take the training data but
you remove all protein information and
then the performance is around here.
So
these models clearly do not really have
an understanding of protein liant
interactions.
So we then filter this training data set
to make to remove this train test data
leakage and see how it looks after that.
So we just filtered the training data
set until all test complexes contained a
unique liance and were structurally
distinct from all training complexes.
This removed about 600 training
complexes
and retraining the state-of-the-art
models on this 4% smaller training data
set um caused quite considerable drops
in this uh benchmark performance. So
this uh
gen score dropped to around this level
here and the previously best one this
pavnosy dropped to around here close to
these simple lookup algorithms.
But of course this is like not a fair
comparison because all these models have
been trained and evaluated in this
setup. So we would have to retrain all
of them and then probably most of those
would also drop after filtering the data
set. So that's why this this figure
doesn't exist. And then another example
um which goes more into the direction of
uh [snorts] integrating domain specific
pre-processing to the data is this
protein thermosability prediction. So
the task here is to
um predict the melting point for
proteins given their sequence.
So
you want to know at what temperature a
protein degrades and loses its 3D
structure because uh it's desirable for
example in biocatalysis to have enzymes
that work at high temperatures because
this can like accelerate uh your
biocatalytic reaction rates and improve
the process efficiency.
And so the models that try to predict
this, they take sequences and then try
to predict a belting temperature for for
this protein. And the training data for
this is is frequently used this melto
atlas uh which contains about 48,000
protein sequences from 13 species and
the associated melting points.
And then what the some models did is
they took these ids that are in this
data set and fetched the corresponding
sequences from the uniro database.
And the problem here is that uniro
contains complete amino acid sequences
as they come from genetic sequencing
experiments. So they also include
regions that are cleaved off during post
translational processing. So you might
have uh your genetic sequence and then
if you would fold this sequence it would
result in a structure that looks about
like this. Um it includes like signaling
peptides so extensions that are only
very briefly attached to the protein and
are cleaved off under like normal
conditions resulting into the mature
protein. So it is not really a good idea
to take these sequences and train a
model on it because um protein stability
is a property of the mature protein and
not of this um protein sequence as it is
in the in the sequence resulting from
the genetic sequencing experiments
because um this is not a structure um
that exists under physiological
conditions and is very unstable.
A third example is a molecular docking
or co-folding.
Um so the task here is to predict the
binding confirmation of a small molecule
to a protein and classical docking
algorithms are simulation based. So the
protein is looked at as static and then
um you simulate different um binding
confirmations and the scoring function
predicts
uh the binding free energies of these
binding poses. And then you try to find
like the location of binding and the
preferred orientation that results in
the lowest energy. And this is then the
final docking pose.
And the co-folding models that we looked
at uh last week, they are usually
diffusion models and they predict the
protein structure and the liant binding
post simultaneously. So they are trained
on all molecular complexes in the
protein data bank
including small molecules and DNAs and
metal ions.
So for example, you could uh give it the
sequence of this protein and the smiles
code of this inhibitor here and then it
would just predict the structure of the
complex immediately.
And examples for these co-folding models
would be alpha fold 3 or rosetta fold
all atom or this recent die model and
the bolts. Um
and if you look at the protein folding
they all have very good performance that
is quite similar to alphafold 2. And
then the second part of the task is this
ligant positioning that it does at the
same time. Right? And these co-folding
models were shown um to outperform the
classical physics-based docking
algorithms. Um so this is this redocking
task. You just take a lot of proteins
that have small molecules bound and you
remove the small molecule and see if
these models can rediscover this native
binding pose.
And then there have been other studies
that actually showed that these models
can interpolate quite robustly but
struggle to extrapolate um to inputs
that they haven't seen during training.
And they also showed that artifacts such
as like steric clashes occur quite
frequently. um so overlap of two atoms
and also that the models are not really
sensitive to adversarial challenges that
you um pose to them. So the f like the
conclusion was kind of that prim these
models primarily rely on like datadriven
pattern recognition and not on an
understanding of uh of the physics of
protein liant interaction and
I would like to show you that using the
results of one paper uh using this mop
kynise system.
So you have this protein this mech one
bound to an inhibitor and the first
challenge that you would give to a
co-folding model is just remove the
liant and see if it can rediscover this
uh binding pose and you see for these
four um co-folding models with the
protein residues. So the amino acids of
the protein in in blue and the original
lian position as it is in the crystal
structure. So the ground truth is in is
in gray and in green you can see the
post prediction of these co-folding
models. So you can see that most of
these models in this specific system
here are able to rediscover the native
binding pose of this small molecule to
that um make one protein.
But then they made this challenge of
binding site removal. So they mutated
all the bindings residues to glycine
which is really like unreactive. So
basically they removed all possibility
for interaction of the ligant with the
protein. And you can see here that most
of the co-folding model still predicts
this native binding structure although
all possibility for um non-coalent
interaction with the protein has
basically been erased by only having
glycine in the binding pocket.
>> Yes.
>> So what would been expected to happen
there was not predicting the vision.
Yeah, actually if if the model has an
understanding of like how protein liant
interactions work, then you would have
expected or we hoped to see some liant
displacement so that it doesn't predict
this original binding pose anymore. But
it just predicts the ligan kind of a bit
outside of the pocket so that it you see
that it has kind of reacted to the
presence of these um unreactive glycines
in the pocket and hasn't really put the
ligant into the pocket.
And then the next challenge they did was
this binding site packing. So it's kind
of similar to um to the previous
challenge with adding a lot of
unreactive amino acids to the pocket but
here they also mutated them to phenol
alanine. So basically removing all
interaction possibilities but also
occupying the pocket with really bulky
hydrophobic groups.
And then you can also see here that most
of the co-folding models still predict
this native binding pose. Um and there
are cases of like unphysical overlapping
atoms and large steric clashes because
the binding pocket is basically already
full.
So
the results uh that I showed you are
only based on about two protein liant
systems. Um but they still show that
these models they have a tendency of
unphysical predictions. um and they show
only a partial capacity to to adapt to
such disruptions.
And so we had to they kind of concluded
that co-folding models are are not
predicting poses based on the physics of
interactions but rather just learn
patterns in the global protein
structures and sequences in the training
data.
So we need kind of traditional better
benchmarks because traditional
benchmarks um primarily measure how well
these models capture structural data and
we also should think about how we can
better integrate like physics into into
these models like basic sc like
scientific principles.
So to summarize this part, um some of
the challenges that people face when
using protein um or biological data for
model training is that um they sometimes
have a lack of understanding of the
biological context. So they kind of fail
to incorporate domain specific
pre-processing which can lead to models
learning um irrelevant or misleading
features. An example for that would be
the the stability prediction using all
the signaling peptides in the sequence.
And then the data set redundancy is a
big problem because random and temporal
splits they are insufficient because
there are so many intrinsic redundancies
and these usually lead to test sets that
are not independent of the training
data.
And then there's also um a lack of
physical um or chemical constraints in
these models. So the models tend to
reproduce patterns that they observe
during training even when the results
are unphysical. So we should um more
often validate models against model
outputs against established scientific
principles and we need to think about
how we integrate these chemical and
physical priors into such tools. And in
general, we just need better data sets
that are um based on a careful curation
and data splitting um strategy and
benchmarks that like quantify the
generalization and also the to and and
also test the adherence to fundamental
physical principles.
Okay. So then I will now transition to
um this denovo design of small
molecules.
So and for this I would like to remember
or refresh this uh diffusion model
principles that you've probably seen in
the previous lectures. So these
probabilistic diffusion models they
achieve state-of-the-art performance in
in image generation. And this works in a
way that they kind of add increasing
amounts of gshion noise over a certain
number of time steps. And then at
intermediate time steps you might still
have some images that have a clear
resemblance to your input image. Then if
you add more time steps at some point
you have basically erased all the
information from that image. And then
you just train a neural network to undo
like these steps of noise. Um and if
you're successful at doing this you can
basically sample from your known gshian
distribution. So basically sample random
noise, feed this to your models and then
retrieve a realistic image that
resembles your input distribution like
you would get another small dog for
example.
And
this spd is one example um of a model
that applies these principles for a
small molecule design. So it's also like
a dnoising diffusion model um that
generates new lians but conditioned on
protein pockets. So it aims to generate
small molecule lians that bind to like a
desired uh protein structure and it
considers for this it considers the
protein pocket as a fixed context during
the diffusion process.
And the lians that this model generates,
they are quite uh novel and really
diverse and they usually ma match the
shape of the protein binding pocket
quite well. And the idea behind all this
is that
traditional drug screening is kind of
limited to the chemical space of
previously studied molecules. And the
hope is that diffusion models can go
beyond this and generate entirely new
molecules, kind of explore some new new
regions of chemistry.
And
to train this model, um, they just used
all the protein liant structures in in a
in a c in a data set called the cross
stopped data set and then added uh
increasing amounts of noise to these um
to these molecules within the binding
pocket. And then the model is trained to
recover this ground truth molecular
structure from the noised inputs. And
then if they are successful they can um
sample through iterative den noising of
random noise within the pocket um some
new structures here new molecules within
the binding pocket.
And
for this we need to know how we can add
like gshian noise to a small molecule
that is bound to a protein. And what
they do is they they first represent
this liant as an atomic point cloud. So
just with 3D coordinates X and the
categorical features H which represent
the atom types and all the molecular
bonds are neglected. So that is this
step number one here. You remove all the
bonds and you represent this molecule as
a point cloud
and then you add noise
um to obtain this noise structure. So
you basically noise the coordinates and
the atom types at the same time. And
this kind of transforms this atomic
point cloud here from aligned with a
molecular structure to just randomly
distributed. And then you they train the
neural network um to rediscover this
structure.
The backbone of this model uh so the
neural network that removes these
noising steps is a GNN. And so these
noised atomic point clouds are
represented as fully connected graphs
and then they are merged with a protein
graph. So the surrounding amino acids
within the pocket but these are not
noised. So then the GNN computes updates
of the liant features H and the
coordinates X that are needed to reverse
one noising step
and the features and coordinates of the
protein graph. So the surrounding amino
acids they remain unchanged during this
reverse diffusion process.
So the workflow works like this that you
have this in the sampling you have have
the your pocket and then you can
basically sample random noise within
this protein pocket and then over these
certain number of time steps you go from
um time t to to zero basically um so
aiming to match your data distribution
again. So you end up with a point cloud
that might look like this. And then they
just add bonds to this point cloud based
on like rules uh how like a set of rules
that defines like how long bonds are
between two atoms. Uh so for example a
CC bond has a certain length and if it's
a double bond then it's a slightly slow
um slightly closer slightly shorter
bond.
Yeah.
If you have any questions about that
otherwise um as I mentioned last time if
I like show you a model it might not
necessarily be because this is the
newest and best model there is. Um so
again for those of you who are
interested there are like a lot of
models for like generative uh liant
design conditioned on the the target
pocket of a protein. Um so target diff
would be quite similar to the one than
you've seen now but it generally results
in a bit higher quality liance. Um and
then drop flow and flow route they are
flow matching implementations of the
same thing. So also the pocket
conditioned liant design but drop flow
has this very um interesting concept of
using virtual node type to allow the
model to dynamically um remove atoms.
Okay.
Then um I will transition to the denovo
design of proteins and show you um two
models that are very often used for for
this task.
So everything that we've seen before now
related to proteins is was basically
protein engineering where you explore
the protein space by just modifying an
existing proteins to optimize its
properties. So the resulting proteins
usually share a lot of their structure
and also their sequence with the protein
that served as an starting point. And in
denovo protein design um this is not the
case. So the idea is that we generate
new sequences of proteins from scratch
and these this does not rely on any
natural proteins but uses computational
methods to generate sequences that might
potentially be very different to all
sequences that have been characterized
before. So there's this statement that
evolution or nature has only explored a
tiny subset of all potential proteins
that could exist.
A famous model that generates the noble
proteins is this RF diffusion model and
it's also applying um diffusion to
proteins to gen generate realistic
protein backbones denovo.
So you can think of it's it's really
similar to what we've seen before. Um
you generate training data by noising
structures of the protein data bank. So
you take protein structures and add
noise until you add this reach this
distribution. And then the model is
trained to recover the ground truth
structures of this noise inputs. And
again you can generate then new
structures through iterative den noising
of sampled random noise.
So we have to talk about how we can now
add gshian noise to a protein backbone
because the model operates
not on entire proteins but on protein
backbones and
more specifically on the framebased
representations of the protein backbone.
And these frames
are these triangles that I talked about
that all amino acids have in common of
this NC alpha and C atoms which form a
nearly planer rigid triangle. And these
triangles are connected to each other to
form this backbone chain of the protein.
Right? And you can basically describe
each of these triangles
uh with a translation and a rotation. So
they model the protein backbone
as a set of L translations and rotations
and then they add 3D gshian noise to the
translations. So they basically perturb
the the C alpha coordinates and then
they apply Brownian motion also to to
the manifold of rotation matrices.
So the noising process basically um
transforms these sets of triangles from
very nicely aligned along a protein
backbone as you can see them here um
into randomly distributed and randomly
oriented and then the neural network is
trained to realign these triangles into
a realistic protein backbone.
Some very interesting aspect about this
model is that in this case like in
contrast to all that the previous
diffusion models that we've seen the
neural network does not is not trained
to predict 1D noising step.
So it is trained in a different way. So
this is basically the neural network
here and it always takes the current
coordinates of these frames of these
triangles and their orientations and
then always directly predicts
um makes a prediction for the ground
truth structure of this protein at this
x0 hat here. So it always predicts from
the coordinates it gets the structure of
the protein that it thinks is most
likely and then um given this neural
network output
and
the input to the next den noising step
is not this prediction of the ground
truth structure but a noisy
interpolation towards this prediction.
So
each step basically gets um a current
set of coordinates which can be this
noisy interpolation towards the
prediction of the previous time step and
it gets always besides these coordinates
also the ground truth prediction
of the previous time step. So this is
not discarded
but you always take um some set of
coordinates and the prediction of the
ground truth that the last time step the
last diffusion step made into the next
diffusion step. So this is what they
call self conditioning. And so the model
can use the positions of the coordinates
at the current time step and the
predicted ground truth uh coordinates of
the previous time step. And according to
the authors um this improved the
performance of RF diffusion quite quite
a lot.
And
another reason for this uh model to be
trained in this way always predicting
the ground truth structure of the
protein is that it's actually based on a
protein folding model.
So it's based on Rosetta fold which is
similar to alphafold. So a model that
takes a protein sequence and predicts um
its 3D structure and it's with similar
accuracy than alpha fold actually and
the idea behind this is that we can
achieve improved diffusion models for
protein design if we leverage the
understanding of protein structures that
is already contained in these folding
models. So RF diffusion was developed
through fine-tuning this protein folding
model. So basically taking um the
weights that can already fold uh a
protein from its sequence and
fine-tuning it on the diffusion task.
So if you look at Rosetta fold this
folding model it's quite similar to
alpha fold. You have this input
sequence. So the sequence that should be
um should be folded into a protein and
then you have also some homologologist
templates. So it looks for structures of
similar proteins that might already
exist and makes a first guess of these
pair-wise residue distance matrix and
then it always
um uses this frame based representations
of of the protein backbones. So it
always includes also this um
first guess of the coordinates of the
protein backbone. So if this is the
architecture of rota fold they basically
um used the same architecture for RF
diffusion but now um the the sequence
input is masked because in this task we
don't need this anymore right and then
this uh homologist templates and the the
first guess of the pair wise distance
matrix is replaced by the ground through
coordinates of the previous time step
and the first guess that Rosetta fold
makes on the frame based representation
of the protein backbone is replaced by
the coordinate prediction of the current
time step
and then um the model is trained in this
way um to always predict the ground
truth structure of your protein.
Starting from random noise it can
generate protein backbones that are
highly diverse. You can see some
examples here on the right side. And
many of the unconstrained designs that
this model generates show very little
similarity to existing proteins, kind of
indicating that this model can
generalize beyond its training data
and also experimental characterization
of generated proteins um show that most
of these are expressible. They are
stable and and soluble.
Another interesting aspect of this model
is that it can be um conditioned. It can
be customized to specific design
challenges for example. So by adding
external potentials
and this is kind of like a guiding of
the den noising trajectory at each step
towards a specific design objective. So
the authors of RF diffusion showed this
by conditioning RF diffusion with the
structure of a tin barrel protein, a
protein that has this overall topology
that you can see here. And then they
could generate um diverse designs that
had this rough overall topology.
Another thing they uh showed in their
paper is that they can build scaffolds
to hold a desired um protein motif. So I
quickly have to explain this because
it's not that simple. So p-53 is a
famous um it's a tumor suppressor. So
it's present in all our cells and
whenever the cell turns cancerous p-53
is supposed to initiate cell death. So
it's supposed to keep tumors from
growing.
But if tumors grow anyway, then they
usually have some mechanism of evading
this p-53
associated cell death. So some mech
mechanism that keeps p-53 from exerting
its function and initiating cell death.
And one way that cancer cells often do
this is by overexpression of MDM2
protein,
which is a protein that binds to p-53
and therefore keeps kind of p-53 from
doing its job. So cell death is not
initiated anymore because all p-53
is bound to this overexpressed MDM2
protein.
And the design task that they took on
now in this paper is to design a
competitor protein that binds to MDM2.
So kind of like a fake p-53
that would bind to all the overexpressed
MDM2 proteins. So that p-53 would again
be free to do its job and initiate cell
death once it's needed.
So they conditioned RF diffusion to
include this um helix of p-53
and then generated some designs that
included this helix. And they showed
that these designs actually bound to
this MDM2 protein quite strongly
and this is kind of like a potential
cancer drug.
Was this understandable?
Okay, bit complicated.
Um
yes, but so far um I've told you that RF
diffusion generates protein backbones.
So you might wonder because the protein
backbone is not at all a protein yet,
right? So it's just the backbone. So
something that you might see here um all
these amino acid backbone triangles in a
chain, but they all don't have anything
attached at their C alpha atom. So they
don't have side chains and they don't
have amino acid identities. So what is
needed to complete the protein design is
u to identify amino acids um that will
an amino acid sequence that will
correctly fold into our desired design.
So in our desired backbone architecture.
So this is the sequence design task. So
you could design a protein backbone and
then you need something to design a
sequence for this backbone and then you
can basically take this sequence that
you designed um give it to alphafold for
example and check if this generated
sequence actually folds into this
backbone architecture that you desire.
So
a model a potential model that can solve
this task is a protein mpnn and it's a
generative model for sequence design
that integrates um also graph-based
representations of the protein backbone.
So it follows this sequence from
structure objective design a sequence
for a given fixed backbone which is also
referred to as the inverse folding
problem.
So you you might have a protein like
this and you represent it as as a
backbone. So only the the the backbone
triangles of each amino acid without
side chains. And then you want to find
the sequence that will fold into this
structure. So you basically have to um
equip all these
um backbones basically all these C alpha
atoms with some
side chains. So that once you produce
these proteins the spontaneous process
of folding will basically guided by the
interactions between these designed um
amino acid identities and between these
side chains. um bold the protein exactly
in this structure that you desire.
So
and for this in protein MPN they model
this backbone as a graph
and the nodes of the graph are amino
acids in this fixed structure. Um so
more specifically the C alpha atoms in
this backbone and then they just connect
all these C alpha atoms to their 32
nearest neighbors.
So through through a graph edge sorry so
it's basically some um contact map. So
that could more or less look like this.
So you have all these nodes that
represent C alpha atoms and then you
connect them uh each node to the 32
nearest other nodes
and then you also need to add some data
or you can add some data to your node
features and your edge features.
So and how they do this in protein mpn
is they um the node features are just
initialized as zeros and the edge
features are initialized as all
distances between the backbone atoms of
uh two amino acids to kind of encode the
spatial orientation of this amino acid.
So
remember that each edge connects to C
alpha atoms. So kind of like here um
between this C alpha atom and this and
then how you would initialize or how
they initialize the the edge features.
So the features of this edge is all um
distances that you can compute between
um the three backbone atoms of these two
amino acids that these C alpha atoms
represent.
And then if they if you have this this
graph here that this very densely
connected graph with these features then
um they have an encoder uh GNN so a
message passing neural network where
these initial node features which are
just zeros and these edge features uh
which are these distances are
transformed with graph convolutions and
message passing steps and in this way um
information about the spatial
environment of each of these amino acids
should be like integrated or embedded
into the node features and edge features
at the certain location.
And then once you have these updated
node embeddings and edge embeddings,
they use this um graph with these
updated representations for um the
second part of the model. So this is
basically what I've just explained. You
have this um GNN setup where you take
your edge features, the distances and
the note features which are these zeros
at the beginning. Then you have this
alternating sequence of edge and note
updates. So you first they first like
update make an a note update with an
information flow from from the edges and
then they update also the edge features
with an information flow of the note
features. And this is repeated uh three
times. So this graph convolution
generates new agent node embeddings. And
um these should encode some information
about the spatial neighborhood of each
amino acid. And then the second part is
a transformer model that does auto
reggressive um decomposition.
So it's going through the sequence. So
at each part of the sequence you want to
identify um a good amino acid right? So
it's going through the sequence one
amino acid at a time. So this model the
second part is run as many times as
there are amino acids in the sequence
and the input to the model is these
updated edge and node embeddings and the
previously predicted sequence.
And then it returns for this position at
the in the amino acid chain uh
categorical probability distribution
from which the next amino acid is
sampled.
Good. So if that is clear then I will
continue with uh the training of this
model. So the training data is um a data
set of proteins with known sequence and
they experimentally solved structures.
So and then they take all these protein
structures and kind of remove all the
amino acid side chains. They reduce them
to only the backbone and then protein
MPN is uh trained to rec rediscover
these sequences that were previously in
this protein. No, this this amino acids,
I'm sorry. Um, and the loss then is just
a categorical cross entropy per amino
acid.
And if they train the model like this,
the sequence recovery reaches around
50%. So of the original sequence of the
protein, protein mpn can rediscover
about 50% of all amino acids correctly.
And you might think that this is really
low or kind of low, but we have to
consider that at many positions in a
protein more than one amino acid might
fit. So there can be more possibilities
um given the structural constraints at a
given location especially in the outside
of the protein.
So the more important thing to do is
this structure validation.
So to find out if these predicted
sequences that you've designed for your
backbone actually fold into this
backbone.
So the workflow is like this that you
have this input structure like this an
experimentally solve the crystal
structure of a protein and then you
reduce it to the backbone and remove all
side chains. And then you have this
protein mpn that uh
designs a new sequence for your backbone
and you pass this new sequence to alpha
fold which predicts the structure of
this sequence and then you can check if
the output structure closely matches
your input structure or not.
So I have a small demonstration here. So
this is the workflow that I've just
shown you and I will now quickly
demonstrate how we can redesign a
sequence for a given backbone. So I will
choose this one MDM2 protein that I've
explained before um that is
overexpressed in many cancer cells and
this is in the protein data bank under
this with this ID. So I can retrieve it
like this and then we have some settings
here. So I can say I want to design four
four new sequences for this protein and
there's also a sampling temperature. So
if we uh increased this then the model
would be kind of more creative about
this selection of amino acids but we'll
leave this at 0.1 right now and I will
run this model.
So, and you can see here now it has
generated four new sequences
and all of these sequences here you can
see have a sequence recovery of about
between 40 and 45%.
So all these sequences share only um 45%
of their sequence with the input MDM2
protein that we've used. And but this
doesn't tell us if this model has worked
right because it's just a sequence. So
we use this structure validation
approach where um we can then see if the
sequence has the same structure once
it's folded as this MDM2 protein that we
used. So I will here run alpha fold on
all these sequences. And this might take
a while. So I will
go back to
to the presentation for a moment.
So protein MPN um solves this sequence
design problem. So finding a sequence
that folds into specific backbone
and the experimental validation of the
generated structures show quite high
accuracy and this graph-based modeling
of the 3D backbone and the message
passing derived note and edge features
are crucial for this model's performance
in rediscovering or in choosing amino
acids that fit at the specific location
And an interesting and important aspect
is also that also here desired motifs
can be integrated by keeping a part of
the sequence fixed during the sequence
generation process. So if we go back to
this MDM2 example, we have designed this
this protein here um that carries the
the helix of p-53
so that our protein then can bind to
this MDM2.
And now because we want this our
generated protein to still bind to to
MDM2, right? It might be a good idea to
use the same amino acids
here
that like the original amino acids in
p-53 because we know that MDM2 binds to
p-53 and we want to keep it away from
p-53. So we just use the amino acids of
p-53 here and then we can like fix this
part of the sequence and then protein
mpn will just design the sequence around
this fixed motif.
So now this has finished. Um we can see
here that we have um
for each of the four sequences we have u
some scores and then the recovery and
also this pldd score which is basically
um
error residue
um deviation from structure. And we can
now look for example at the one that is
the best one sequence one. And you can
see that um if you compare the newly
generated uh sequence once it's folded
without fold to the um
structure of MDM2 that you can see in
gray then you see that this really
closely matches um the input structure
that we used. So we have been successful
now in generating some sequences that if
we fold them or if we would produce them
uh in a lab then it would have the same
structure as this MDM2 protein.
Let's go back to the presentation.
So diff SPDD that we've seen is a
diffusion model that generates um new
small molecules uh new small molecule
binders for specific protein binding
pockets and the combination of RF
diffusion and the protein MP9 that we
have just seen is one potential approach
for the no design of protein proteins.
Um I I'm saying one potential approach
because um there are many more models.
This is a really um competitive field
and you can hardly keep up with all the
studies that are published in protein
design but this is one very good
combination of models that is frequently
used. It's publicly available um and
they work really well but this has in no
way been an exhaustive uh lecture on on
this field. So
and the very interesting and use like
important aspect is also that these
models can be condition to include
desired motifs or have desired
topologies. So this allows the design of
proteins for specific applications.
Good. If there are no other questions
then I'm at the end.